حرصت في هذا الموضوع انا اتحدث عن ما هو
اثر ومنجزات معاويه بن ابي سفيان في جانب
السياسه في جانب الاقتصاد في جانب تاسيس
الدوله العربيه الاسلاميه التي يعني اسست
امبراطوريه كبرى في العالم في ذلك الوقت
وكانت الدوله الامويه ومعاويه سفيان هو
احد من وضع ركائز حقيقه النظام السياسي
العربي الذي كل من جاء بعده
استلهموا واستفادوا والتزموا بهذه الطريقه
[موسيقى]
انا اتحدث لك عن شخصيه معاي بن سفيان ماذا
يعني فعلا هذا الرجل هذا الرجل معاويه بن
ابي سفيان هذا الشاب اليافع اللامع الذي
نشا بين بطحاء مكه وجبالها ابن سيد سادات
قريش هذا الرجل الذي خرج الى الشام في ظل
احداث مضطربه وملتهبه كانت في العالم
الاسلامي بعد احداث الفتنه قام معاويه بن
ابي سفيان في ذلك الوقت بحمايه وحفظ
المنجزات الحضاريه التاريخيه التي تحققت
في عهد الخلافه الراشده فاسس معاويه بن
ابي سفيان واحده من اكبر واعظم
الامبراطوريات التي عرفها البشر في زمانهم
في ذلك الوقت التي هي الدوله الامويه
الامبراطوريه هذه الدوله الامويه كانت
اكبر بثلاثه اضعاف يعني حجمها اكبر بثلاثه
اضعاف من الامبراطوريه الرومانيه هذه
الدوله الدوله الامويه بلغ نفوذها وامتد
نفوذها الى جميع قارات الارض المعروفه
بذلك الوقت اسيا واوروبا وافريقيا هذه
الدوله حكمت الثلث العالم
[موسيقى]